oh nothing to see here just a seafloor
turning into a wriggling mass of hair
good news is it's not here even better
news these are a righteous variety of
eel specifically their garden eels so
named because someone got high as hell
and decided this look like a garden
thousands of these things can gather in
one patch of seafloor and while they may
look like a collective nightmare they're
actually harmless plankton feeders see
them jerking around they're snagging all
the tiny animals floating around in the
oceans currents and notice how they're
all facing the same way that's a good
indication of how the waters flowing but
you can't see most of the gardening its
burrow is deep enough that it can fully
retreat if a predator approaches to keep
that burrow from collapsing the eel
excretes a goo that cements into a tube
all it has to do is anchor itself with
its highly muscular tail and wait for
food to come to it not a bad life if you
ask me that is if you can get up the
crowds
you